même si tf1 est une chaîne en déclin
j'aime en déclin ce casting est indigne
c'est de la sixième division
vous ne voudriez pas un seul dans une de
vos émissions
soyez honnête chine a été chez nous
c'est même qu'il ya aidés à nous voir
tout ce temps c'est à ims les prix de
cette catastrophe syrie même fait même
sûreté fixera un naufrage
alors oui cette agression pardon c'est
pas de savoir si vous les avez beaucoup
il ya plein de gens qui sont charmants
mais si on devait mettre tous les gens
charmants la télévision bon allez je n'y
serai pas est ce que je veux dire par là
c'est que homo au moins sloan pardon oui
c'est une artiste elle l'a connu à l'élu
des titres et danse à elle explose ça
peut être très drôle
j'ai des autres j'adore capucins jamais
rien arrêté comme si la chine est
devenue cyril c'est qu'est ce qu'on a
fait c'est ça qui est intéressant failli
faire du théâtre avec elle l adorable
beaucoup de qualité tu prends moins de
24 ans personne ne cause juste il faut
prendre le casting dans son ensemble
très bien le faire si oui dites la
vérité vous le casting vous trouvez
comment je pense qu'il faut prendre des
vieux et des jeunes c'est ce qui ce
passe à cissé pourrait peut-être avis là
mais je vais rien avant vous en faites
ah ouais vous et moi je veux dire un
truc avant tout c'est que ça va pas
toucher grand monde pour voir en bas
puis ils ont refusé benoît dubois mais
capucins c'est un petit peu pareil ouais